so i like these like big things software
companies that can scale but when i
heard him describing this i'm like
god i want to get in on this like this
is still like you know what i mean
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be
what i want to
what's up sean here we got sam and
today's episode we're going to talk
about
a blue collar side hustle aka the
hillbilly of the week
which is a vending machine business and
sam breaks down all the numbers behind
it
we talk about this idea of creating the
edible arrangements
of doordash through ghost kitchens we
talk about the new
uh hottest app in the app store the
number one app
aka is this the next snapchat is this
the next clubhouse we don't know
it's called paparazzi and i tell a story
around that
and we talk about vimeo a you know a
business you've probably heard of but
may not realize that vimeo is now a 8
billion dollar business
and then at the end we shoot the [__]
with abreu and uh the new abra you dan
and you get to meet him a little bit so
that's the last i don't know five ten
minutes of the episode
all right great episode enjoy all right
what's up
yo you know what's funny i put out that
thing
for um for merch designs and somebody
had a great one
that was all right so the funny ones i
thought were somebody made a yada yada
yada shirt
with your face on it i thought that was
funny and then somebody made one that
just goes
it's both of our faces it's both our
faces like kind of illustrated and it
just says
i'll pray you we good which is what you
say at the end of every episode
do i really yeah i uh and then another
guy so sean we're doing this meetup in
miami um
by the way i feel like that undersells
it right
live show we're going on tour that
sounds more badass than we're doing a
meetup
well yes you're right but there's two
things going on here the first
i was downplaying it because i frankly i
didn't know how many people are going to
show up
yeah so we set the limit originally at
and then uh our venue now is changing
and so we don't i don't know how many
going to see
right so we capped it now at 3 35 that's
how many rsvps we have now
so if more open up we're going to open
it up when i was doing it to like
make it so if i failed it would be okay
um
and also so when you're talking about
show i know that you're i think you're
pretty comfortable on stage and you
actually aspire to be kind of a
professional comedian i have no idea
what we're actually going to talk about
we haven't even we haven't even said a
word to each other about what are we
going to do there
yeah so uh we'll figure it out but
basically the way it's working and
we agreed to as per usual we agree to
stuff without thinking it through
but basically we have a thing in austin
at 6 00 p.m
on thursday that's probably going to end
at 10 p.m
and then we have a 7 a.m flight
and i think that flight is gonna land at
noon
12 30 in miami these are the logistics
people came to listen for
well sorry but anyway
it's just we have a lot we're going to
be running them out a million miles an
hour you know what i thought was would
be
a fun idea i just thought about actually
while i was putting my contacts in
before this
i go what are we going to say on stage
what would be a good live show because i
was like either
we just do research and we just have
like a fire episode where it's like
great ideas great billy of the week
great business breakdown we could have
that ready
i said or we could do it you know like
when you go to a comedy show and they
[__] they take your phone
they zip it up so you're like you can't
record this it's like
well if they showed up live what can we
give them that special that we can't
just say on air
so i thought maybe i think each of us
probably has a few
business stories war stories that we
could share that are
entertaining that you could do kind of
an off the record
format um and i feel like we could put
out
five stories that we could tell about
stuff
you know or three or four stories at
least that could be
entertaining about you know uh something
something
something that happened that is uh you
wouldn't just like
you wouldn't go publish a blog post
about it because it's not necessarily
the details you can't get out to
everybody
but in a trusted group of some of our
you know biggest fans i think that's
cool a 400 person
trusted group but yeah i think that's a
group of strangers
i think i think maybe it might default
to like
q and a but we'll see um it's gonna be
weird
we're gonna i've never i've talked i
think the most amount of people i've
ever talked in front of is 5 000 and
that's not a big deal i can do that all
day
but never 5 000 people who came to see
me just like riff
so that's going to be weird but uh we've
got a lot of ideas
and you want to get straight to it yeah
let's do it where do you want to start
you want to actually start
the vimeo one's not an idea you have
this cool thing about paparazzi or po
i don't actually know how to say it yeah
that's actually a lesson i want to start
with vimeo because there's no lesson
here i just thought it was cool
so did so vimeo went public two days ago
i didn't even know this until i saw the
tweet it was an awesome tweet about
uh the woman uh was with her kid and i
and saying like wishing her mom a good
day's work when it goes public a good
day's work to you know like uh
child like good good luck it was like a
three-year-old saying you know good luck
as you ring the bell i
i i i love that type of [__] uh and
anyway
uh went public but there's a background
behind vimeo so do you use vimeo i use
it all the time
i've you i've used it i think everybody
runs into vimeo once in a while i don't
use it to
upload unless i'm like oh i need a high
quality kind of private thing
and i'm just surprised this company made
it it just seemed like video was dead i
think it literally died at some point
but they pivoted and made it actually
into a great business so tell me about
it
it never died so it's always been like
kind of popular like for a very
particular type of person i love
watching it on my tv because i've got
like a fancy tv
and they have fancy videos like high-end
videos and they particularly have like
weird stuff
weird music they've got what sort of uh
fancy weird videos are you watching like
like like waitress stuff oh there's like
yeah
tons of nature stuff like women stuff
like what are you watching oh
like uh like um like a drone flying
around or something
gotcha or or you know stuff that's like
it's just it's kind of like it's uh
oddly entertaining
or they'll have really unique art pieces
like an art video or
so it's very niche but it's really neat
i love it but the way it started is
actually interesting so
these guys it was a guy named ricky van
i think his name is ricky van veen
he started with a guy named josh and it
started and a guy named zack three of
them they were only 18 and they started
this company called college humor
and you know college humor of course
we're a similar age we
if you're young and listening to this
you probably don't know it but basically
it was like
[__] jerry but before instagram
exactly or bar stool sports but not
sports
right and it was like a kind of a smutty
it wasn't smut but it was like snl
online and it was cool and it was one of
the first blogs
and they started it and it got going and
they also uh had little side projects
these guys lived in new york
and they were just like your typical
like 20 year old cool new yorker guy
where they like you would see their life
and
they would start little side projects it
was really fun one of their side
projects was
a video uploading tool that they built
because they were uploading videos
before youtube was around
and that was vimeo and barry diller who
we have to do a deep dive on he's very
fascinating he started this company
called iac they're pretty huge they've
owned match.com which they spun out to
be his own business
they own uh tinder they want a ton of
stuff angie's list
and anyway he bought that for 20 million
dollars in 2006
and he's held it now for almost 15 years
vimeo
they spun it out so what barry diller
and isd does is they buy these companies
they employ people
to run them and they grow them not like
crazy fast they grown
and then they spit them out to go public
and it works often
and they went public recently they
bought this business for 20 million
dollars
it's now worth 8 billion is that crazy
that's insane publicly traded worth 8
billion by the way
if vimeo is worth 8 billion youtube's
worth what
800 like youtube must be youtube is yeah
more valuable than vimeo so that just
seems a little off right like
dude vimeo does like four or five
hundred or six so
it's like many almost close to uh it's
half a billion ish in revenue
yeah but youtube there's like 20 billion
in revenue it's crazy right it's like
yeah well i'm agreeing with you youtube
should be worth a lot but i don't think
vimeo
so explain the niche so vimeo basically
did what they went they sort of pivoted
from consumers uploading videos to more
like
businesses or creative people filmmakers
you know type of people uploading videos
is that right yeah so if you want to
upload a video and you want to upload it
quickly and you want to
upload it in the highest uh highest
quality possible you'll use vimeo and
you'll buy a creator's account they also
let you do some editing online that
makes it a little bit easier you can add
some captions things like that
uh you can have a people will use it to
like store their portfolio
um and so what you'll see if you go on
there and you type in like nature you'll
see some video and like then you'll see
like oh wait this has this is by yeti
and it's yeti hosting a lot of their
cool videos that they'll pay a creator
to make for them as like an ad and
no i don't actually know where they even
display those videos other than vimeo
but uh like you'll see um what's the
code com what's the
outdoors company that uh let my people
go surfing north face the north face guy
like you'll see him fishing in a stream
telling like the story about the
background of the company
right so it's a lot of uh outdoorsy a
lot of brand stuff it's pretty
interesting
uh the niche i don't actually know how
to describe that niche but it's kind of
interesting
like it's all people who want to have
higher quality stuff than youtube
in terms of like resolution and they
also do a couple things that they like
goes against their culture
like they don't have view counts they
don't have a sort by popularity thing
so it makes it a little bit easier to
discover to discover uh stuff that you
normally wouldn't have seen
well it's good by then because all the
other video upload sites whether it's
like dailymotion or like all those other
ones
they all died right youtube just uh
youtube youtube took over
it ate it ate everybody up and vimeo
squirted away and found a niche that
works for them that is actually like
an eight billion dollar niche right it
ended up ended up working out and not
like a
oh that's a lifestyle business kind of
way so you know props to them because i
don't think this was the
i don't think this was what most people
would have bet was it would be the
outcome
once youtube started growing like it did
so the company vimeo has 200 million
uh users so 200 million people a month i
believe go and use them
and also they have 1.6 million paying
subscribers so pretty substantial
um another company that i didn't put on
here but
is killing it in video do you remember
weebly yeah
oh sorry not weebly what's the other one
sort of the w w
wistia you know wistia so whiskey is in
the same thing
so wistia is kind of an interesting
company they also start in 2006
and they were based out of boston and
they raised a [__] ton of money
built this business to be like 30 40 50
million recurring revenue and then they
bought out their shareholders they
raised money from pp
uh from kkr the pe company and bought
out their
investors i bet you that company could
be potentially worth a billion dollars
as well
um but they're kind of doing something
similar yeah you know when
last episode i had this thing or not the
mark lower one but the one before that
where i said
you know one of my one of my learnings
that one of the counter-intuitive things
that i learned
is never underestimate these mega trends
uh even when you feel like you're late
you're early
um and there's another version of that
which is even when you
even when you're niche you're big with
with a mega trend and so
uh mark zuckerberg came out i don't know
what it was
i didn't start using this term megatrend
until i heard zuck use it
i think five years ago when he goes
video is a mega trend
i thought oh that's interesting
facebook's not even at that time
facebook wasn't even about video they
hadn't launched
watch the feed was mostly photos and
text updates
and but they see everything right
facebook knows what's going on on the
internet they know exactly where
all the opportunities are whether they
can capture them or not
and for video i thought huh
what does he mean by megatrend and i
think what it means is like mobile
like the internet like now video social
these were um there were like trends of
trends
meaning like they were going to
transform basically every space and so
you saw that
we saw this with video all of a sudden
newspapers
are you know the kind of the meme in for
media companies was we're pivoting to
video right
um which is like used to write articles
and now you produce videos um you know
same thing happened with with
instagram you know more and more
instagram content shifted from photos
to videos either through stories or
posts or now like reels or tick tocks
and so video just has just eaten up more
and more share of people's attention
and what the internet is used for and i
think that that's pretty
pretty fascinating and i think this is a
good example of video is such a big mega
trend
that even being the niche kind of like
the the video uploading site for
creative makers hobbyists fishermen and
photographers it's like boom eight
billion dollar you know 80
billion dollar company if you end up
winning that space that niche and so
yeah just another example of do not
underestimate a mega trend
don't think you're don't think you're
late when it's a mega trend and
don't be afraid of going niche because
even the niches are big with megatrends
i would say
today's mega trends my personal bets are
that today's mega trends are
anything that's actually real in machine
learning or ai
as well as crypto i think those are the
two mega trends that are happening right
now
speaking of mega trend something
happened the other day
an app like went crazy viral and you
kind of have an insider story of it
yeah a little bit okay so there's this
app so i'll i'll tell you kind of my
my my learning here friend uh friend of
the
pod actually he's never come on but one
of our friends or i don't know if you
know him very well
he's got nikita beer he um he's an
entrepreneur his company
was tbh got acquired by facebook for 100
million dollars in a really crazy
way uh they basically were grinding
trying to build like social products
like you know the next
the next twitter the next snapchat for a
while
many years and we're just getting really
really smart about it
learning a bunch of stuff but never
hitting the home run and i think about a
few months before they ran out of
ran out of money they just threw you
know they were either gonna wind it up
just
all right let's all go get jobs or you
know get aqua hired somewhere
they uh they threw one last attempt and
they made this app called tbh
and it went viral amongst high schoolers
it was like a app where
you're kind of like answering questions
or polls about
your friends you know who's most likely
to blah blah blah or
who is your favorite person about blah
blah blah um
and then it was a place to go you know
can i post like a social network for
high schoolers
takes off facebook buys it for i think
100 million bucks was the reported price
how do you think that deal was
structured 100 million dollars for an
app that
doesn't like it's brand new i have no
idea
um obviously it was an overpay you know
months later
tbh shut down uh you know no longer it
was kind of a fad right
it didn't have legs uh they shut it down
and they kept
you know some most of the talent and so
anyways he's been there for a little
while
so he tweets out when the app store
refreshes there's a new king 500 000
installs on day one
all right you got my attention i'll bite
what is it
and people start speculating what it is
and i thought sort of i i sort of
do some internet digging and uh
and i find out okay there's this app
called paparazzi so have you seen what
the app is the app is called paparazzi
it's currently the number one app in the
app store
it's had over a million installs and i
think less than a week they're
they're wait list basically they were a
test flight app which is like how you
give it to like
uh beta testers it's not even in the app
store
their test flight app went viral and so
they had half a million people
ready and waiting to download the app as
soon as so they just they just rushed it
onto the app store
and bang they hit the hit the number one
i think they're still number one on the
free charts
above snapchat above tick tock above
facebook above above everybody
and um okay so what is paparazzi
and by the way paparazzi has almost the
same story as tbh
these guys been working on this for a
while they
like three years i think years yeah they
were just kind of grinding away
you know small team i think they're in
la and um
two brothers they they almost got
acquired or kind of aqua hired for
single-digit millions of dollars like
you know a couple of the big social
networks were talking to them
they could have took that you know they
would have made probably you know
a million bucks two million bucks
amongst themselves if they did it
but they said all right [__] it yolo
one more try they released this new app
paparazzi and it
hits um and it hits big and so we'll see
if this is gonna last right no who
social lapses could be like a tbh could
be like a clubhouse
it could be the next snapchat right
that's the thing with social apps is
they all start sort of start up start
out looking the same they look kind of
silly they sound kind of dumb
and then you know you fast forward a
year and then you know some people are
proven right i told you that was dumb it
faded away
and then for some people like me my my
you know i think i was right about
clubhouse my famous clubhouse prediction
that
i think is being proven right you know
their their downloads went from like
1 million to 4 million to 10 million and
then back to 2 million 1 million half a
million right so you have intel are you
are you right
i mean the download numbers would tell
us a story that i'm right so far
now but when i was saying it it looked
like this thing was going to take off
they just had 10 million downloads in a
month which is insane
now it looks like i'm right but of
course it could turn around they may you
know maybe they could uh maybe they
could turn me wrong but how did this one
app get
to get popular so uh so i don't know
exactly how
how it got popped it's very cleverly
architected the way their sort of flow
works to get you to invite friends
but i think it was just like a novel
hook with this so why is it called
paparazzi
it's called paparazzi because on every
other social network
you post about yourself right i go post
on instagram i post a photo from my
camera that i took about
me and my life and if i post a story
same thing
paparazzi is just like the name sounds
it's other people
taking pictures of you which is kind of
funny right so like
your profile is not pictures you upload
about yourself
which tends to be you kind of in a
manicured setup
environment making yourself look good
with paparazzi it's
other people taking pictures of you and
that sort of is like a photo tag onto
your wall
and so your whole profile is just
pictures that other people
took of you and you can sort of like
accept them or deny them if you don't
like the photo or whatever
and so that creates a cool dynamic where
now you're getting people in more candid
shots because it's other people taking
photos and which makes the
content more interesting it's more raw
than what you're getting on
on facebook it's more raw than what
you're getting on instagram it's even
more raw than what
what snapchat was which this is the game
snapchat played on facebook
snapchat was more raw and candid because
the photos disappeared so people
they had less of a filter on what they
posted but still they wanted to you know
post a certain type of thing that made
themselves look good
this is even more raw than snapchat it's
even more candid it's
content that wouldn't have made it to
snapchat
makes it onto paparazzi which is what
makes it interesting now you're getting
new [__] shared that you wouldn't have
otherwise got
so that's the premise of it what do you
think of this never in a million years
but i thought this was gonna work and i
can't decide
if i just have bad taste or if i'm old
um
is that the app i'm opening the app
there's like a hype video do you uh
which is cool
more apps should do that they should
have like a trailer like instead of a
boring onboarding
this thing is playing me like i want to
play the music
it's like let's get it pop in and then
there's pictures of all these like cute
boys and girls my phone is literally
vibrating
it's like that's the most excitement an
app has ever shown me
so do you but when you were looking at
this did you think that this
so i get that it's popular now and it's
easy to say
yeah i get it but no i would have never
predicted this right like okay you would
have told me i've been like
huh that's clever but still probably not
gonna [__] work
right like it seems so unlikely
for anything to just like hit like this
is so unlikely
and it's not the expected things so you
sort of by default you sort of
you don't imagine that this would hit
same thing with clubhouse i was like oh
that's cool i've seen a bunch of things
like that
i don't really see why this one will go
viral but it did and so it's very hard
to predict with social even
i spent like maybe like five six years
of my life trying to build social stuff
i knew everybody in the space i
tried so many different things so i i
would say
i'm not like a novice to this stuff but
it's very very hard to predict and
our friend jack smith says this best he
goes if you look at even the guys who
invested in snapchat
or whatsapp or whatever they go and they
start like
okay sequoia the best venture fund
that's you know ever existed basically
they invest in whatsapp they invested in
every single round of whatsapp they led
every round which was a genius move so
when
exits were 1920 billion bucks they were
huge winners out of that
cool guess what they also invested in
yik yak a social product that died
whisper
it's those products that died right like
they have a graveyard of other things
they tried
that didn't work out and i don't know if
those are the exact ones that they
invest in but they have
a bunch and so jack pointed out he's
like if even the best guys who have had
the home runs
have a bunch of swings and misses with
social it just shows how hard it is to
like correctly predict social before it
plays out
i have a friend who who who was in the
seed stage
um a friend of a friend he was in the
seas stage of robin hood and
uh a whole bunch of other stuff uh and
probably worth multi billion for sure
worth multi billions and
someone was asking him about social apps
and about consumer stuff and he goes
honestly if the person is competent
maybe do it but
really it's just gambling and i have no
idea which one's going to work he said
he goes with b2b stuff i can kind of
like i can look at some stuff i'm like
okay i understand you can
you can cut you can the likelihood that
you can make this at least a mild
success is quite high
but with social and some basic consumer
stuff
it's just i'm just rolling dice and i i
have very little confidence in any of it
so the beautiful thing about social like
who it's like who would
try this right like because you're right
it's so hard to predict if you're a
great entrepreneur and you go into this
space
you are inten you're going to a casino
and you're saying all right
my odds at the craps table or you know
51 i'm a 49 to 1.
49 to 51 i'm 49-51
oh you have you know whatever chinese
backgammon over here okay
i'll go play pai gow i'm gonna go play
paigo even though the odds are you know
80 chance of loss it's like why do you
do that because it's a it's fun
and b when you get social right you're
the [__] king of the universe right
like
it's like yeah my app is the one that's
used by like a billion people
every day of their life their whole
social scene is on here they use it with
their mom their friends their
their girlfriend boyfriend whatever and
so it just hits different when you hit
social and that's that's why i love even
talking about
things that are social that hit because
it's a rare type of game that you kind
of have to be a madman to go play
so let me bring up something that's the
total opposite of this which is you
don't have to be a madman
and and the likelihood that it's going
to succeed is incredibly high
but it may not be like a huge winner
okay just with that information do you
know where i'm going with this
i see vending machines on our thing and
i i think that a vetting machine
business is probably the most
predictable
simple understandable guaranteed type of
business you could do is that what
you're going to
yeah so these uh two folks came to me
and they pitched this idea they're
raising money for it
it's a vending machine business uh for
it basically it's mostly female products
so tampons and stuff
in uh bathrooms and oddly enough i had
another guy email me a deck about a
vending machine business and i'm not
going to do that one but this first one
was kind of intriguing
they've got some traction they're making
money it's kind of intriguing
and i started doing some research and i
tweeted out who knows everything about
who's the person he talked about vending
machine it got a ton of traction for
some reason i think it's a lot of people
are interested in this
this guy named quinn miller reached out
to me and i did a call with him this
morning
very fascinating he worked and i just
want to bring this up because this is
the exact
opposite of what we were just talking
about right but it's oddly
as compelling and as interesting even
though it's
the two totally different uh parts of
the world
so this guy he's 27 he worked in
software sales he quit about a year ago
to start this business
he's got a vending machine business and
he gave me all of his numbers and he
said i could reveal it so he's about 10
months into the thing
he's currently doing 15 000 in monthly
revenue
and he's doing that across 27 machines
his startup costs were 600
500 or 400 to buy a machine and 200
to fix it and move it to the place where
it had to go by the way this is
our weekly blue collar side hustle
this is the great college side hustle
yeah so on the 15 000 in revenue
65 is profit so he's doing around uh 97
a month in profit so far total
investment into the biz
so far after he already bought his first
machine has been fifty thousand dollars
time involvement per week relatively
high 20 hours a week because he's
actually delivering all the stuff
i asked him all about i was like how
does this work because the reason i
reached out to this guy was i was like
hey
uh there's this like tampon startup it
kind of looks interesting what's your
tampon vending machine startup what's
your opinion he goes
yeah i mean i obviously don't know
anything about that
like too much but basically my opinion
is the world
uh he goes america runs on coke and
monster energy drink
and i was like what do you mean he goes
let me let me explain so i put these
vending machines i love that
so let's slow down so so the guy
basically buys vending machines like
you and i are used to just a snack
vending machine nothing nothing
innovative there
well he does one quote innovative thing
um
he puts uh he installs a credit card
machine on him for about 250 bucks you
can get a credit card
okay so he gets a vending machine he
says all right people aren't carrying
quarters so i'm going to take cards
he puts them uh he puts them so he buys
each machine you said for
500 bucks the first one was 500 he has
27 machines
uh with 50k so whatever that math is so
what's that
2k a machine roughly yeah okay so he
buys a thousand to two thousand dollar
machine
he puts it in places like what office
building department yeah
so he cold calls uh lower income hotels
uh motels assisted living places in in
uh low-income apartments
so sorry low-income apartments dash or
comma motels
comma assistant living places okay
and so he goes and he basically says hey
put this here and he
there's a revenue split or he pays rent
how does that work so most of these
businesses the way that they work
is they give 10 to 20 to the real estate
folk
right uh this guy he goes i actually am
because i sold software i'm pretty good
at sales
and i do what's called a value sell and
he goes basically i say look
your tenants are if i just improve your
tenant experience by just a small
percent
maybe you're going to make more money
because someone will want to stay or
want a rent
he gives him nothing he gives them
nothing and so he's got
a bunch of machines in like 10 different
locations and he just cold calls them
and then it's so unsophisticated where
does he get his stuff
costco so he buys a can of coke from
costco for 33 cents and he charges a
dollar for it
right uh it's very simple uh not
complicated at all by the way my
grandfather used to have a vending
machine so this was probably the first
business i ever encountered was
i think i was probably five years old
and my parents you know they worked so
my dad would work in an office building
and he needed me to be babysat but then
like you know old people also kind of
need babysitting
so my dad went for a two-for-one he
basically
bought or rented out a little like kind
of like a
corner store inside like a little deli
inside of the
office building and um and then my my
grandfather ran it and we used to go
like
work the register at the age of you know
seven um and
he was like baby baby he basically he
occupied his grand
grandparents and his kids without having
to like do any
pay for any like caretakers in fact it
made a little bit of money and then my
grandfather had this vending machine
that we used to go and do this exact
refill we would go to costco
buy the cokes put it in he would collect
a bag of like
change and then we would like go to the
bank and like
exchange the change and i remember being
like what is this he had one vending
machine
as his business it sounds awesome and i
asked the guy
by the way this guy's name is quinn
miller i'll give him a shout out quinn
miller
i asked him i go how big can this get he
goes look i'm not trying to be offensive
or anything
but the operators of these businesses
typically are pretty hillbilly
um and so they're pretty unsophisticated
which doesn't mean they're dumb they're
just not sophisticated in terms of like
technology or anything like that
and they like there's a low-key easy
life he goes but i met a guy in palm
springs who had about 1600 machines and
he was making anywhere from
five to 10 million in revenue with about
half in profit
right and i was like well that's pretty
amazing how
else can it get big like what else is
big and he said there's a company called
canteen and i looked it up i
i think it's public uh but they do like
15 billion in sales of this and they're
the largest vending machine company in
america they operate them
yeah and they do distribution so the
thing is is like what this guy does
uh quinn he finds he finds his route so
he finds a route so he's like all right
if i go from destination a to b
it's a straight line i'll do everything
in between and so i try to find
locations on the way so one truck can do
all of it in an easy short amount of
time
and he's like i'm very specific specific
about where i choose and that's where
you make a lot of money is you can be
very efficient with your time
and so basically that's what he does and
he said this company can't team just
does that on a huge scale and they're
ultimately at the end of the day a
logistics company
and a bit of a supply chain company but
at this point quinn told me he was like
i rented a small warehouse now because
i'm getting so much freaking coke
he goes the reason i like doing that and
so back to tampons he goes
you have to like look at what the repeat
purchase rate is he goes if i go to like
a lower income
area these folks love coke and love
monster to the point that one guy will
drink five cokes a day i'm getting five
dollars from them you have to ask
yourself can you get that for
uh tampons or other products and he goes
in fact a lot of the money guys once
they move
from coke and monster energy they're
starting to go with into what's called
honesty market so basically at a wee
work
you know how they like you swipe your
credit card and you only take one
sandwich for eight dollars yeah
he's like that's where the money is
right now huh that's so
and um yeah that's so it's almost like
there's whales for the vending machine
it's not like
everybody buys one every three days it's
like
one guy drinks nine cokes a day uh or
you know four red bulls
you know a week and that's where you
make your money is on the like 10 of the
of the residents
who buy like 90 of the goods or
something like that probably
yeah this guy was interesting man he's
only 27. he's the
lives in san diego worked in tech sales
he told me that uh he goes
like basically i'm a pr he goes i'm
pretty i was pretty good at selling
software
um i'm not the best but i'm pretty good
and this industry that i went into
they're just kind of not that great at
that many stuff and i could outsell
relatively easily i could kind of
outwork relatively easily
and so anyway fascinating story so
you know we have the billy of the week i
think this needs to be the hilly of the
week
it's the hillbilly business that's
actually of the week
that's actually great uh so quinn miller
you are
the hilly of the week congratulations uh
i love this business so just to
summarize buy the thing for a thousand
bucks
cold call you know um apartment
complexes
motels hotels you know low income the
better
i guess is the way that this market
works and then
you're trying to generate he's
generating off of uh what'd you say
50 50 machines 27. 27
off of 27 machines he's generating about
100 to 120k
of profit uh a year and so that's you
know that's the business and then
what's the work uh it sounds like it
could be easily
you know delegated but sounds like he
wants to do it keep his margins which is
you go
you buy the stuff wholesale and then you
stock all the machines on some regular
cadence and you collect
uh you know the payments on the other
side so i was so
fascinated so like i get uh when people
call me a tech guy i'm like
not really i work in publishing like i'm
a publisher but
i guess compared to someone who works in
vending machine i am a tech guy
and so i like these like big things
software companies that can scale but
when i heard him describing this i'm
like
god i want to get in on this like this
is just so like you know what i mean
like it's like we just got done talking
about paparazzi and how this young guy
named nikita who sold an app for a
hundred million dollars to facebook
and is probably 26 years old baller
like dot you'll die a billionaire if you
just breathe okay
that's it but then i hear the [__] about
this guy who spent 50 grand
and is gonna make a hundred and fifty
thousand dollars a year in profit and
i'm like
[__] yeah sign me up let's get into this
so
i think it's kind of interesting i like
hearing about it yeah whatever floats
your boat
you know okay let's do some quick like
other ideas or other brains
so i think first of all i'll say the
beauty of this is that you don't need to
come up with a genius twist on it you
just do the same thing in your local
market and it would work
okay so that's that's cool but if you
were gonna do a twist right like i i
like to dabble in ideas so let's let's
come up with some ideas
here's a couple that i think might be
interesting as twisps
you mentioned um the honesty market what
do you call it honesty market
that's what he called it yeah so um i've
seen this at big companies they do this
um like at the adobe office i remember
they did this which is like
there's a bunch of sandwiches in a thing
you take it out and you pay and nobody's
watching you so there's no labor cost
and uh they just hope that you're not
gonna steal [__] and
that works in certain types of like
high-end places you said wework things
like that okay i think that's cool
so maybe there's an out there maybe
there's an opportunity there
what about subscription so you if you're
taking my credit card
and you got this vending machine how do
you get me with saying
hey you could buy this one right now you
could buy this one can of coke for a
dollar
but for uh you know six dollars a week
and get unlimited coke
or you can get unlimited vending machine
swipes and uh
and you basically set up a recurring
revenue business off of the residents in
the
in the place and um you know it's like a
breakage model so you you know you
they just can't empty you out and dude i
think that's the move but you're wrong
it's not unlimited no no it's capped
right but the machine caps you
it's like oh hey it's user whatever i
don't know how they would know that
you're
you're you i guess that's a little bit
of a tricky one you have to swipe your
card every time
which feels bad you just need like a
metro card you know like a like a like a
metro card or
exactly you need a clipper card or
whatever where you basically get a
certain amount
so the question is this if someone's
gonna if you're gonna spend
so when i lived in college i had a
vetting machine would i spend 30
a month in that vending machine i think
yes i think i did yeah
yeah i think i did we had snapples and i
couldn't resist right
so then the question is you just have to
ask yourself are you willing to give up
of your revenue in order to give the
customer a discount if they pay up front
yeah but you know i think it works both
ways so you get two benefits one is
they prepay so you float all the money
that way and you're able to like cash
flow the business better
the second thing is not everybody's
gonna maximize the value so there's like
a breakage
model where some people use the full
amount
um great and you know
if 30 of people don't max out that's
just free money for you that you didn't
have to
send a dime on and uh easily you know
most of
i think this is the the ugly side of
most subscription businesses is that
people don't use the subscription they
just don't remember they don't cancel
uh they're either too lazy or they
forgot and you sit here thinking you
have all these happy customers
and in reality go look at your usage
numbers how happy are they if they
haven't used you in a you know a year
and a half and you're just charging
their card
and so that's the truth about
subscription businesses why people love
them is because the people set it and
forget it
and uh and so yeah i think the same
thing would happen here all right so
that's another idea
last one i'll bring up with this vending
machine thing is
i'm buddies with the guy who started
life aid he came on the podcast
they have yeah i remember that fit aid
party aid you know recovery aid whatever
sleeping whatever they are they have a
bunch of different drinks i'm like
addicted to fit aid
it's like my whole mini-fridge in my gym
here is stocked with them
and he got his break by giving he he
basically went to crossfit gyms and he
said hey
crossfit you don't have a mini fridge i
will give you a free mini-fridge and a
case of fit aid
here you go you know here's a 79 mini
fridge and a case of fit aid
um try it out give it to your people let
me know what they think
and uh if they like it or if you like it
and you guys making a little bit of
income off this just give me a call back
or you know i'll send you a second case
uh next month
um and so this is how he grew the brand
was through the crossfit
um the crossfit gym network and
specifically with this
idea that they didn't have fridges so
they didn't have a vending machine they
didn't have a fridge
and they couldn't have a vending machine
because you can't be crossfit and then
sell kitkat bars
that doesn't work and but what you could
do is you could make the
the post-workout machine and you could
put it in
every gym what's in the post-workout
machine it's gatorade propel
it's you know fitted it's all all the no
no i'm just
saying you could do this this is idea um
and then you have like you know
i mean the bcaas like the branch chain
amino acids you should take post-workout
as a little supplement
you know you could have hydrant for your
for your hydration needs so you could
put a whole bunch of
post-workout stuff that people take
protein powders protein pre-mixed drinks
you could put it all on a vending
machine and put it and put it in gyms i
think you could have a similar model
yeah i think that could work i would i
don't know actually what the margins are
on health food versus a coke uh i
imagine they're the same to be honest
um but i'm into it i think that those
honesty market things i bet works
shockingly well
yeah i remember when we were doing the
sushi restaurant we met the guys who
started like i don't know panera or
something like that
and panera bread was doing this actually
i think in st louis
they opened up the first yeah they're
from st louis the first like pay what
you want
uh restaurant so pay what you can i
think is what they called it at the time
which is like
anybody could go and you could eat and
you just pick what you want and at the
end it says
pay whatever you want the average person
pays 12
and uh what he said was that the average
ticket price in that restaurant was
higher than their normal ticket
than their normal uh restaurants where
they have fixed prices you would think
oh people are going to scam you and
cheat you
anybody says it's a bell curve 20 of
people go over
20 of people go under and most of the
people pay the exact same
you know but when you look at how the
exact numbers break down it's a little
bit higher because people eat more
and um because they feel like they're
getting a deal and
the customers were happier because they
didn't you know it's like kind of like a
feel-good story
so i thought that was kind of
interesting then again i also when he
was talking i was like this sounds a
little bit like pr
so uh i'm gonna like discount what
you're saying by like thirty percent
here
i might do this for fun do what
i might do the vending machine thing i
think it's i think it's a great idea i
think you should do it as the uh
just basically build it in public for
the podcast i think you should you
should basically give us updates on how
the vending machine business is going
i think i will i think i'm gonna do it i
love it i think this is a
fun weekend thing you want to talk about
one more thing you want to do uh ghost
kitchen for gifting
yeah so um so it was my trainer's
birthday yesterday or two days ago
and i was like uh [__] i want to get him
something
what do i get him right and so i was
like okay
i'm not great at buying gifts buying
gifts is like a huge pain in the ass
i'm a procrastinator so like today is
his birthday so i can't like order
something online it's not gonna arrive
it's gonna clearly be like i ordered
this on your birthday it's gonna arrive
three days later
that's [__] up yeah that's who i am
i'm [__] up right like that's just the
reality of the situation and so i was
like okay well what do i do
that what can i do now that will like
arrive today
and how do i be a good friend who's also
a lazy bastard and so my go-to recently
has just been
i just surprise older people postmates
or ubereats stuff like i'll just like
i'll just order you know like two jamba
juices to somebody's house
and they're like uh and i'm just texting
them be like hey
uh you know there's something for you
outside and they're like what and they
go and they pick it up or
they you know the person rings the
doorbell and says hey this is for you um
and people love this [__] uh i it
happened to me somebody on my birthday
instead of giving me a birthday gift
they just
ordered me food from one of a restaurant
that i like and i was like this is
fantastic
and like sometimes the logistics don't
work because you're like not there or
whatever like it's not perfect
but um these the food ordering apps i
think they recognize this because now
like recently in all their apps they
kind of have like a
gift a meal like option but um
what it made me think of was oh what's
the actual
business what's the if this is um
[Music]
you know what that phrase is where have
you ever seen this diagram where there's
like a street or like a
a walkway where you're walking and it's
like a l right like i walk straight then
i turn left and then there's like
if you cut across you get there faster
and you could see in the grass people so
many people have cut across it's like
worn out it's called like a happy path
or something like that
like a desire path uh it's basically you
show what people actually want to do
it's called the desire path
and so similarly i think the desire path
here
is not to randomly order food have to
ask your friend for their exact address
hope that they're there to receive it so
you can't really surprise them but
instead
why don't people make why doesn't
somebody make the version of like edible
arrangements
or like one of these like gift basket
products on top of ubereats and post
base and all these companies that we
already use
so if you're on top of doordash already
has my credit card
i'm already opening the app every day
why doesn't somebody make the best way
to just send a gift product to somebody
else as a ghost kitchen
on top of this i think this is a
no-brainer successful idea
what does edible arrangements do oh you
never had
basically it sends like a kind of like a
platter or gift basket to somebody
yeah yeah yeah yeah i know that in a
like um
cool format and this business does like
hundreds of millions of dollars like
it's a very very successful business old
school business
no i i get that but how do they
how do they like how is this any
different than you just ordering
food for someone so what edible range it
looks like a gift like it's a
it's like a gift basket and you want to
do that for a restaurant
no i think somebody should make a ghost
kitchen on top of ubereats and doordash
that is specifically a way to send food
gifts to other people it looks like a
gift it's like a giant chocolate thing
right interesting it's like a giant
fruit fruit arrangement it's a it's just
you know hearts and strawberries and
chocolate cover strawberries or whatever
right like it's stuff like that
and it basically and like instead of you
know when doordash says customize your
order you're like you know i'm allergic
to gluten
instead of this it's like what's your
gift message we have we print it out we
put it in there right like
the thing you want to be a thoughtful
person is like a cool looking thing that
looks like a gift and it comes with a
little message
but i want it as a last minute option
and the way to do that is as a ghost
kitchen i think
so i was talking to andrew this last
podcast and then i talked to him
afterwards i called him i go hey
what were you talking about was pretty
interesting tell me more so he started
this uh
uh a bakery bakery basically
andrew is being andrew he's always
tinkering and uh
he was like i want low carb like
something to satisfy me like bread right
and so he he uses this thing called
sucrose i think
some monk fruit some alternative
sweetener right
and he got the guy to he hired a chef
and he paid him a small amount of money
single digit low hundreds of dollars to
come to his house for a few hours and
make these recipes single digits love
hundreds of dollars
what does that mean like i don't like
two three dollars
no like uh single day as in not like 800
or i guess
that yeah okay right now you've got a
few hundred bucks gotcha yeah a few
hundred dollars to come and make
a bunch of muffins i think is what he
made okay and he had him use this monk
fruit thing he goes
this is sick and he designed a website
called uh
i forget what it was called something
like i forget he made a little website
on shopify
for the brand and then he put it on a
doordash or uber eats and he sent it to
a bunch of friends and he only did local
delivery
in victoria and he had the the meal
delivery company
dude he sold like three grand in month
one worth of stuff and he's like
invested
eight thousand dollars into it so didn't
make a profit but it kind of sit
he was able to test this idea very
easily and he's i'm like
man of all the stuff that you do this
like agency that which makes more way
more money
this bakery thing is so much more
fascinating than like just
you know doing a design design work for
someone this is way neater to me
right and anyway so i think you could
test this so easily
yeah totally because you could just rent
out a commissary kitchen for
the hour right you don't even have to
commit to very long right so you can
rent these things by the hour so you can
rent it for
a couple weeks a few hundred bucks maybe
maybe a thousand dollars max
you list your your restaurant on uh your
fiverr or logo you
list your your ghost kitchen on on
doordash or ubereats
you pick one city and you start and if
this works you basically just
you become the easiest way for people in
that city to send a thoughtful little
gift to others the key
is you don't have to spend the money
acquiring customers right so like you
could have always done this business
but you would be competing against you
know 1-800 flowers and edible
arrangements and
i forgot what the other ones like david
something we send like
chocolate like i did this for my
neighbor my neighbor lets us use their
playground with my kid
and so i sent them like a big like
chocolate gift basket or something like
that because
i don't know i need to do something nice
and i don't want to make anything so
like
you know how do i spend 100 and give a
thoughtful nice gift to somebody make
them happy for for five minutes
and uh so i did the same so that's what
i want to do
but i don't want to have to go google
search and figure out the brand and then
like
go through their website input my credit
card no i already open doordash six
times a week
it should just be there my credit card's
saved i push the button and it goes to
the person and it's it's done what's
your grocery bill
every month is do groceries are insane i
don't know if i'm insane or if
inflation has happened but i went to the
grocery store
no joke last two times went to the
grocery store it's 450 to 500
for me my wife and i have a like you
know i have a baby who drinks breast
milk because i don't even that doesn't
even count
and then we have like a you know 20
month old so you go to whole foods
it's whole foods but like whole foods
you didn't it wasn't a 500
trip for me before it was like a 200
trip so i think we got like a little
crazy being like yeah
let's buy these like nine dollar juices
or something like that i don't know
what's happening but
that's crazy what's yours uh i would
have to look but i
imagine it would be between one thousand
to fifteen hundred dollars a month
one thousand okay so that's like 400 a
week so about the same
yeah but my thing is even before i had
anything
i would always spend a lot on it because
my logic was
what's the point of living if you don't
feel good and so i'm gonna buy the
highest quality stuff
i know i don't care about price yeah my
logic was i want this uh i really want
to eat this right now
look like when it comes to books i don't
care what the price is same and i don't
even care if i read it if i just get one
sentence
yeah it could change my life forever so
i don't care like there was one time i
saw this book and it was eighty dollars
i'm like oh my god
i'm like nope i don't care i'm buying it
um
mostly it's the same thing with
groceries so like the healthiest
uh freshest stuff that like like for
example i used to buy like kroger
that's like the grocery store in
nashville like kroger generic cheese
and like if i thought about that now i'm
like oh i can't even think about eating
that right now
well do you do the thing where you're
like you look at your parents and you're
like yo
what were you thinking like yeah cheese
in a can
and like yeah this was like everything
yeah every thursday we used to eat like
you know like um like totino's uh you
know pizza rolls and like
takadis or whatever those things are
like or like yogurt
[Laughter]
yeah same exact thing that was the
regular food we ate that wasn't like the
one-off thing
if you asked my mom what a carb is i
don't think she could still tell you
so like i just this is good it has carbs
i'm like no mom see that's the problem
you know this has carbs and you're like
yeah pasta
that's a good hearty meal i'm like no no
no no mom that's like
because she's still like you know but i
can't even blame her dude the food
pyramid
the food pyramid how big of a lie was
that that was like a middle finger to
america
the bottom of the food pyramid is like
get your grains and your carbs and
cereals and pastas and breads
and then like vegetables has this small
little half slice
on the third layer like fruits and
vegetables just got like you know shoved
in last minute right right next to
dessert
it's crazy yeah like if you how many
grams of sugar are in a can of coke
ballpark you know i think it's like 30
40 grams yeah it's
great so you that's the ball part yeah
so i think it's like a little bit more
than 40.
if you ask my family like growing up how
many grams are
they're like i have no a million i don't
know like what is the
what is it what's the gram yeah like i
don't know and also like
if i told them 45 they'd be like i don't
is that
right 45 like is that good like we're
not we're not 100 sounds good to me
they wouldn't know um so i think that
there's something here
about uh like growing up i i middle
school
i used to eat the school lunch in texas
i grew up in houston texas in middle
school
and this is my first time where like mom
stopped packing my lunch and i started
to buy the school lunch six
six seventh grade and straight up every
single day
i ate a frito pie which is by the way
that's not even like a meal like you
can't go to a restaurant and order a
frito pie because all it is is it's a
bag of fritos emptied into a
basket and then chili and cheese put on
it like nachos
i ate that every day it tastes [__]
amazing by the way
but i ate that every single day as a kid
and my parents
where was the intervention that's what i
want to know where was the intervention
that that should not have happened
i definitely think it's changing now i
don't think it's changed entirely at all
but i think it has yeah jamie oliver
died for this man he tried to
change the schools or whatever yeah the
naked chef um so
yeah so when it comes to like budgeting
i for food i just
whatever because like i'm putting this
in my body okay
i need it to be like the best stuff so
um
but i did just drink like a diet dr
pepper yeah
i was gonna say pretty sure i've seen
you just like just house like a whole
halloween
that's a small child's like halloween
hall i do a podcast one time
it is it is a huge weakness of mine but
uh whatever i i mostly do good uh we
will
i'll have to do an update so i've been
i'll i'll say it now i've been taking
trt now for about a year
yeah and both sean and i invested in
this trt company
called peak it's switching its name now
but it's switching its name
um and i'll like do an update on it but
basically like
i took it not to change my body i took
it because uh like i was feeling
down and i got tested and they're like
oh your t's real low
it has made me jacked
like totally jacked like i i
feel like i'm still feeling down but
dude
so we're gonna have to do an update on
this and i like i told these guys i was
like
you know like i don't know if i want to
post a shirtless pic but i might be open
to it if you want to do like a like a
because they're appealing to like nerds
right and i'm like i'm that if you
but i look like a kind of a shredded
nerd right now maybe i could be like
your
you want me to post a pic like a before
and after i will but uh
oh my god this trt stuff i feel amazing
that is crazy so you were taking this
before but you switched peak is that
what you did
i took it for a little while and then i
got off of it when i got
uh when i got lime i cuz i couldn't get
like a refill something like that and
then i got like
and then i'm back on it again now um and
i and i started using peak
pretty cool service i'm not telling
anyone to take this by the way don't i
mean just like this is like some doctor
[__]
yeah but it's pretty awesome yeah if
don't come to our podcast for either
financial or medical advice to be honest
yeah but just say what we do and what
works for us that doesn't mean it's
gonna work for anybody else
no no promises for anybody i'm eating
whole foods and i'm shooting up with trt
and like your body's transforming my
body is completely transformed in the
last six months
um i'm just like crazy strong i have
pretty low body fat like 15
which isn't that low but pretty low and
i just feel like a professional athlete
so it's pretty awesome that's amazing
congratulations i think now we know what
to do with the live show
you just need to take off your shirt i
think that's going to be your
contribution
and then i'll prepare some content well
i sent you a pic
and someone was like you look like a
white ape you're like
yeah you do you look like a gorilla you
look like uh
you were like you looked like stunning
like when you wear your shirt like right
now if somebody's watching on our
youtube
channel which you should youtube.com
hustlecon i think is it yeah
um if they see you right now they're
gonna be like
like i'm not meaning this as an insult
but you just look like an average person
right now
yes you sent me that picture and you
looked like my bodyguard like you looked
you looked like somebody i would hire to
protect me
which was insane yeah it was crazy so
anyway we'll do an update about that my
birthday's coming up in june and i
thought about
maybe i'll post a shirtless pic just
like why aren't you
um why don't you wear shirts that make
you look
more jacked you wear stuff that like
makes you look non-jacked are you trying
to do some clark kent
superman [__] i don't know it's not
intentional
i it's not intentional i don't think
about it
[Laughter]
so we um meandered a bit we'll see if
this turns out to be
any good no dude that was great the
vending machine stuff alone
was the price of entry i think people
will you know go check out paparazzi
vimeo
that was okay uh and then the ghost
kitchens for gifting i think is like a
cool idea but nobody's gonna go do that
but i think the vending machine thing
was the star of the show today
what do you think abreu or should we ask
dan
because abreu you know handing off the
baton to dan so
let's start with dan and then let's go
to a brayu let's go for the apprentice
and then the master
all right i liked the paparazzi
i i like the vimeo um the vending
machines i don't know i looked at that
when i was in high school actually
oh damn the contrarian i love it yeah
and then the ghost kitchens i don't know
you guys use doordash and stuff
maybe i'm just too old i don't use that
stuff
yeah i feel like that's one thing that
i'm always like yeah everybody uses
doordash six times a week i'm like oh
wait probably
probably not probably most people don't
but that way people wait
dan you don't use door dabs or you don't
i like to cook
yeah but what do you do when you don't
want to do it
we go out to eat or i'll pick something
up i don't think like you like to cook
all the time yeah he's like i like to
cook it's like dude but you eat
what do you do for the other 18 times
i've been intermitting faster i also
like because
yeah i also like to have that in common
yeah i did i cooked too last month
i don't think it's even i don't think
it's even an older person thing like
it's just expensive you're just paying
so much for the delivery
yeah but like what do you do when it's
like when you're hungry
when i have an eight-figure access
i i guess yeah you cook every meal yeah
just about
but i also eat like chicken nuggets for
lunch so
yeah yeah okay so give me give me give
me yesterday's menu what did you eat
breakfast lunch yesterday
and snack yesterday um i'll start with
dinner it was mashed potato
kielbasa frozen veggies um
toasted hawaiian uh hawaiian bread
whatever it's called
um lunch is always the same thing it's
uh carrots
and chicken nuggets every single day
so i feed my dog yeah and then morning
it's just like coffee
okay what's kielbasa that's like a it's
like a sausage yeah
yeah polo sausage with hawaiian bread
and what
um mashed potatoes frozen veggies dude
so you're not on the whole foods tip
dude that's
yeah you're eating like my mom my mom
top you're eating like my mom taught me
to eat
you're starting a company up right it's
like at least go in the whole foods
scholarship and eat and you gotta like
when you're on the whole food
scholarship you gotta
you fill the plate with the hot food and
then you take a cart and you walk around
while you're eating it
and then you just and then you just try
that um
you can pay him back when you're done
okay but like that's that's crazy to me
damn what do you eat
i feel like now i get now i feel like an
[__] is this what i'm supposed to be
doing and i'm supposed to be
eating kielbasa for dinner what what i
have a little uh instant pot spice pack
business
so make an instant pot meal a few times
a week so i got some
damn coming in hot with the plug what is
it what's the business
bonniespices.comispices.com
so you put spices into the spots and
then what you put just like chicken in
there
yeah so the biggest thing i thought was
the challenge with the instant pot was
measuring out all the spices if you
wanted to make something
so i had a butter chicken recipe took
two minutes to do everything but the
spices
so we sell a pack that's compostable it
has the recipe has all the spices you
just open it up dump it in
makes using an instant pot much easier
that's not a bad idea okay what's uh
how's the business doing i
kind of went on hold when covet hits so
i'm spinning it back up
why would it go on hold for kobe like
you had to go on hold yeah i ended up
losing all my clients i was
doing consulting for events and that
kind of disappeared
i see i see okay gotcha and so you uh
you pause the business okay but
are we talking are we in the tens of
dollars hundreds of dollars thousands of
dollars tens of tens of thousands
like the hundreds of dollars a month so
okay all right so everybody go to any
spices order something let's get them
into the thousands of dollars
uh i'll get one what's your best one is
butter chicken rice butter chicken i
have a little indian three pack we have
a rogan josh an indian curry lentils
and a butter chicken if i take off my
shirt i also have a little indium
that's my nickname for sean
i mean that was easy you just yeah thank
you for the assistance
uh dan what's the url a n i spices dot
com
a and i spices dot com
yep all right and dan uh so abreu grades
us at the end of every episode
what'd you give this one i thought the
vending machine thing was worth it
that made it an a minus everything else
was a
so in the a's thanks the vending machine
and then dan are you uh
are you more simon cowell are you harsh
or are you paula abdul you just give
everybody a's what's your
what's your grading style uh let's do
this one as a b plus
i feel like there's a bray who's
literally has
never given us a b it's only an a it's a
a minus or a dude it only used to be b's
you guys started actually doing some
work and you got some a's
all right fair enough all right good
stuff let's uh let's
let's leave all this in this is fine um
people can people can enjoy this
so all right we're out of here see you
in austin see you in miami
i bought my tickets this morning
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be
what i want to i put my all in it like
no days off
on the road let's travel never looking
back